[Music]
this morning we have a follow-up on a
story from yesterday how china is
cracking down on children playing online
video games anyone under the age of 18
is only allowed to play three hours a
week except during holidays geez thanks
it's part of a larger concern in china
about the impact of too much game
playing some kids are even going to
rehab to deal with it raymond ascencio
reports
in china video games aren't just a
pastime they're a way of life for many
youth but at packed cafes like this one
in beijing it's game over after beijing
announced a draconian crackdown on this
kind of youth gaming culture among the
rules no playing video games at all from
monday to thursday and on friday
saturday and sunday play is limited to
one hour a day between 8 pm and 9 pm
state media pushing the government line
no industry can be allowed to destroy a
generation
some of that generation find themselves
here at a digital detox facility to
fight addictions to video games cell
phones even the internet here young men
and women live structured boot camp
style days with counseling and group
therapy accommodations are basic with a
communal eating area but they're not
alone their parents live here too it's
all part of the program
this man told cbs news his son spent
eight to nine hours online each day and
would steal his money then disappear for
months
this boy unrelated told us he fell in
with bad people before being sent here
telran is the man behind this rehab the
director was a people's liberation army
colonel with a specialty in psychology
he says 85 percent of miners have some
kind of internet addiction we asked paul
haswell a tech and online media expert
in hong kong about the gaming crackdown
what does that mean for the tech
industry for the gaming industry though
i think it's quite bad new bad news for
some of the homegrown ones i think 10
cents are going to struggle the most
because of this tencent is the creator
of honor of kings one of the most
profitable video games on the planet
right now its stock plunged 10 percent
on august 3rd losing 60 billion dollars
in market cap when state media described
china's gaming culture as electronic
drugs and spiritual opium tencent stock
has since rebounded but beijing has now
made it clear protecting many would say
policing the country's future generation
is more important than any company or
any family for cbs this morning raymie
in ascencio hong kong
i mean beyond the sort of as a gamer i
find it very strange to do that but
there are some interesting aspects of
why you would want children to play
fewer hours on video games yes well i do
get that but to be told that you can
only play at this time on this day by
the government yes i tried to talk to my
12 year old about it yesterday and he
said dad let me finish this game
then maybe we can talk about it
vr